it's black history month and you know
what that means nothing it doesn't mean
anything to anyone conservative black
people don't care about it because
they're excluded from any recognition by
the liberals who established and run the
whole thing leftist black people don't
care because to them every month should
be Black History Month conservative
white people don't care because we don't
have any racial Consciousness and
liberal white people don't care because
they don't respect or have any Act ual
interest in black people other than to
instrumentalize them for their own
political purposes which is how you end
up with awkward scenes like the one that
just transpired in Target's Black
History Month display so I went to get
my kids this little magnet learning
activities since black history coming up
from Target I don't know who's in charge
of Target but these need to be pulled
off the shelves like
immediately so I teach you was history I
study history got my major in social
studies and I noticed some discrepancy
SE like as soon as I open this like I
said these need to be pulled off the
shelf for starters this is not Carter G
Woodson this is WB the boys peep the
stash peep the stash they got the name
wrong this is not WB the boys this is
Booker T Washington peep the little
fancy bow tie peep the fancy little boy
bow tie and then this is not Booker T
Washington this is Carter Woodson
you can see clearly clearly the
similarities I get it mistakes happen
but this needs to be corrected
ASAP of course they misidentified Booker
T Washington the most conservative and
inspirational of the Civil Rights
reformers of course they're going to
write him out in favor of the Socialist
web Deo but they don't recognize Deo
either the libs who put this thing
together don't recognize any of them to
the libs black people all look this the
same because to the libs black people
are all the same and that's worth
celebrating apparently I'm Michael
nolles this is the Michael nlls
[Music]
show welcome back to the show now that
the Apple goggles thing is out a bunch
of people are walking around like
dummies with the mask on actually some
are driving with the Apple mask on we'll
get to the Brave New World in one second
first though I don't want to move off of
black guys too quickly because a very
prominent black guy by the name of
Killer Mike just went on Bill Mah's show
Bill Maher begged him to endorse Joe
Biden here's killer Mike's answer what
are you feeling on the election coming
up I mean Biden and Trump are you as
depressed about that as most people as a
choice my my feeling is pick your policy
not your person find
out this
is this is not the Dallas Cowboys versus
your favorite team this is this is the
policies that will affect our
generations for the next 20 30 40 years
to come so close your eyes listen to the
policies that are being pushed so that
means
therefore that means I'm I'm for black
people in happy black history mon but
you're not you're not saying one
candidate over the other hey man my he
ain't going to get me in no trouble
tonight but you can't get yourself to
say vote for Biden over
Trump you you want me to list it now so
now now we got I'm just saying can he
get himself to apologize for the crime
bill can he get can he get himself to
get his head out of his ass and say
black people you you are black
regardless I need you to tell me what I
need to do can he pick a call of former
people who are affected by Drug law
street gangs recidivism and crime and
say I need you as a board to advise me
how to fix federal prisons if he can do
that absolutely I can so my challenge is
out there all right Killer Mike there's
my there's my fellow Killer Mike when
when Killer Mike and I are together we
we are killers Mike kind of like
Attorneys General but of course Killer
Mike and I disagree on substantively
almost everything he just said right
there he and I don't like Biden we agree
on that we're not endorsing Biden we're
not going to vote for Biden but the
reasons why not are totally the opposite
Killer Mike here brings up the Joe Biden
crime bill as far as I'm concerned
that's the one decent thing the man has
done in his entire political career it's
good to put criminals in prison
president Trump passed the first step
act which was something of a jailbreak
Bill and at the time I was quite
critical of that bill but the people who
supported that Bill said well maybe it
can pry off some democrat voters and
that will weaken them politically and
it's a small price to to pay politically
I I felt it still wasn't worth it I
didn't think the juice was worth the
squeeze
but maybe there's a chance that in a an
election of Trump versus Biden when the
Democrats haven't changed all the rules
and it's not widespread mail and voting
based on covid and after three years of
Biden completely destroying the economy
and opening up our borders and dropping
to the lowest approval rating of any
president in modern history at this time
in an election year maybe there's a
chance that Trump actually is able to
pry off some of those traditionally
Democrat voters especially black guys uh
Snoop Dogg just came out he was asked to
criticize Trump Snoop Diggity Dog
apparently said that he has nothing but
love and respect for Donald Trump and I
think it's because Trump pardoned one of
his friends I don't know the exact
details of it but whatever the reason
this is a reminder of something about
Donald Trump that I think unset settles
a lot of uh political nerds and
ideologues
namely he assembles kind of a weird
Coalition namely Donald Trump shakes
things up namely Donald Trump speaks
about issues in some ways that
traditional conservatives really like
like when he talks about uh protecting
American industry and when he talks
about rebuilding the American family and
when he talks about Law and Order I
think conservatives like that a lot and
he talks about about issues in ways that
conservatives don't like like when he's
trying to
let criminals out of prison
but regardless of what you think about
Trump he assembles an unconventional
political Coalition and politics is the
art of
inclusion politics is the art of the
possible to quote ovon bismar it is the
art of the second best politics exists
in real life to quote cocaine Mitch
McConnell the winners go make laws and
the losers go home this is why it drives
me crazy when some
abstract writer in in the Beltway area
attacks an ordinary conservative who's
actually doing something in public life
because that that actual conservative in
public life isn't following the fiveo
manifesto that so and so wrote in
National Review or whatever well these
conservatives you know these these PE
they're compromising on their principles
says the
random Beltway apparat chick who's
writing in the the uh suburbs of
Virginia without ever putting any any
skin in the game without having anything
really on the line in real life politics
you've got to assemble enough people to
win elections you've got to advance a
policy agenda that will be popular that
will be implemented and that will get
you reelected and so I'm none of this to
to defend certain bill bills and policy
proposals from Trump or any other
conservative that that are um improper
or inappropriate but it is to
say all Republicans have to do is pry
away like four to 5% of the black vote
and the Democrats lose the Democrats
lose basically every election and is
that going to happen I've been burned
one too many times on thinking that this
is the moment that the Republicans
finally win over a huge portion of the
black vote but I don't know maybe maybe
we've never had an election like this
we've never had an election where an
American original Donald Trump is
running for a non-consecutive second
term against the historically least
popular president maybe in American
history at a time when there is a
political shift that's been rumbling for
at least a decade
now I'm just saying maybe I'm just
saying maybe it could happen you can
read about these things for yourself and
when you want to go read things online
you ought to check out expressvpn right
now go to expressvpn.com
does it make sense that the same company
that controls half of online retail also
passively EES drops on your private
conversations at home big Tech is more
powerful than most countries and they
profit by exploiting your personal data
it's time to put a layer of protection
between your online activity and that is
why I use expressvpn every site you
visit video you watch or message you
send gets tracked and data mined when
you run expressvpn on your device the
software hides your IP address which is
how big Tech identifies you expressvpn
makes your AC be harder to trace and
sell to advertisers Express fan encrypts
100% of your internet data to keep you
safe from hackers and EES droppers on
your network that is why expressvpn is
rated number one by CET wired tech radar
and countless others what I like most
about expressvpn is how easy it is to
use download the app on your phone or
computer tap one button and you are
protected stop handing over your
personal data to the big Tech Monopoly
that Minds your activity and sells your
info protect yourself with the VPN that
I trust to keep me safe online that's
expressvpn.com
KW that is
expressvpn.com to get three extra months
for free go to expressvpn.com
right now to learn more speaking of
questionable laws this stupid border
bill has been presented to the US Senate
you I don't even want to call it a
border Bill what's the what I guess in
as much as the bill pertains to the
southern border it opens up the Border
more so in that way it's a border it's
not a border security bill it's just a
border bill it's an open border Bill and
we're we're now getting even more
details about this stupid bill that poor
Senator Jim Langford the Republican from
Oklahoma is taking the fall for but it
was a bill that was negotiated obviously
by Senate leadership by Mitch McConnell
and Chuck Schumer and it's complete
trash it's so totally unacceptable that
even I give a lot of Grace to cocaine
Mitch I think he's a pretty effective
political leader even if he's not a rock
ribbed conservative but this is just
pure garbage her Senator Tom Cotton
here's what this border security bill
will do it'll give the secretary
Alejandra mayorcas the right for the
first time ever to Grant Asylum claims
to Grant American Citi citizenship
ultimately to illegal aliens at the
border without review by immigration
courts so you give the guy who very well
might be impeached for the the terrible
job he's done as the uh Secretary of
Homeland Security you're going to give
that guy unilateral power to make new
American citizens that's not great the
bill would codify catch and release so
the the border patrol arrests these guys
and then just as a matter of law they
would release them into the country
never to be heard from again this would
be under the so-called alternatives to
detention for any alien that says that
they intend to apply for Asylum or
another protection so not hard to see
how this is going to play out the
illegal aliens who give their life
savings to the drug cartels they're
going to go up to them and they're going
to say okay here's all my money and the
coyotes and the cartels are going to say
okay here's what you say yo kiero Asylum
when you get to the border patrol agent
then they just they're just going to let
you out into the country this is the
border security Bill uh the the bill
would give immediate work permits to
everyone who says that he wants Asylum
as long as he passes an initial
screening by liberal bureaucrats you
think they're going to pass I think they
probably will so okay in stly you get
work permits that'll be great for
American labor by the way right that'll
be really good for the working class so
glad to see the Democrats fighting for
the little guy again by depressing their
wages to nothing the bill would Grant
50,000 extra green cards per year this
is a time when the United States has
over 3 million foreigners coming in
immigrating into our country every year
more more than that I guess it's more
like four million plus four four and a
half million because you've got 1
million legal immigrants and then you've
got another what 3 million illegal
immigrants and and and this is the time
when the Liberals say okay you know what
we need you know how we're going to
solve this problem we're going to have
more legal immigration no the problem is
we have too many people coming into the
country man we got 320 330 million
people 4 million newcomers a year is
just too much it's especially when this
has been going on for 60 years
especially when we intentionally don't
assimilate anyone it's just too much no
knock on the Guatemalans I like them
very much as a people but we can't take
the whole country we can't take all of
Venezuela we can't take all of Ecuador
we can't take of Nicaragua we can't take
all of it's just too much man we got too
many people coming in we need to cut it
out we need to greatly reduce the number
of green carts we have in this country
especially because virtually all I mean
the vast vast majority of new immigrants
are coming from the same parts of the
world how does that Aid in the supposed
diversity aims of the mass migration it
doesn't Aid at all you know what it aids
it aids it giving Democrats a permanent
majority which is what this whole bill
is about the bill would guarantee new
government funded lawyers for illegal
aliens that's good I was afraid they
wouldn't have top legal counsil the bill
would not limit Biden and mayor's abuse
of immigration parole this would allow
them therefore to continue using parole
as a way to let people off the hook
issue work permits to any illegal alien
who can claim an urgent humanitarian
reason and then here we go this is the
this is the cherry on top of this
garbage Sunday the bill the Border bill
would send billions of
of foreign aid all over the world in
ways that would not help us for instance
billions of dollars of nonmilitary
humanitarian quote unquote Aid to Gaza
without any safeguards so I'm all for
sending humanitarian Aid to whomever
deserves it but you really think you're
going to send Aid to Gaza that's going
to go straight to the poor Palestinians
who are being oppressed but not a chance
it's going to be taken by Hamas which is
the the government of of Gaza and it's
going to do what theoretically we're
backing Israel in the war between Gaz
and Hamas so then we're going to fund
Israel some more so you know what we're
going to do we're just going to fund
everybody and blow everything up with no
strategic end in sight and we're going
to squeeze that into the Border bill for
some reason the Border will which
doesn't close the border it opens it it
is
so it shouldn't Astound me anymore
because my expectations of the
Republican Party should be below the
ground at this point but did it if you
sent me to Washington DC and you said
Michael
write the worst possible bill on an
urgent policy matter that you possibly
can I would struggle to come up with
this bill that's how bad it is I don't
know what Jim Langford was thinking Jim
langford's always been a perfectly
amiable Republican senator the fact that
Mitch McConnell got him to take the fall
for this thing absolutely pathetic and
they thought they were going to get this
thing through two weeks ago one week ago
for that matter they really thought they
were going to ram this thing through
complete
trash now thankfully even if there's a
little confusion in the Senate and look
there are great Senators Tom Cotton come
out against this uh Mike Lee in Utah has
been very forceful against this Senator
Cruz I mean all the good guys in the
Senate have come out strongly against
this thing but in the house the House
GOP leadership has said this is dead un
arrival this is a joint statement from
speaker Johnson and Steve scales and the
rest of house leadership they say any
consideration of this Senate bill in its
current form is a waste of time it is
Dead on Arrival in the house we
encourage the US Senate to reject it
which I bring up because one that's
really really good if the house kills it
it's dead thankfully the Republicans
control the house barely but we control
the house unlike in the Senate but
two does this mean Matt Gates is
Vindicated you remember Matt
Gates puts on a big show pulls a big
stunt and throws out Kevin McCarthy the
leader of the House the Speaker of the
House
and he did that because he said McCarthy
has betrayed conservatives and he's lied
to us and he's Squish and we don't want
him anymore and when Matt Gates threw
him
out all of the establishment types
including self-styled conservatives
freaked out they whined they complained
I didn't even have that much of a a
grudge against Kevin McCarthy I thought
he was a little bit squishy but compared
to the previous speakers in recent
memory he was the most conservative of
any of the I suppose I'm damning perhaps
with faint praise but I didn't didn't
hate the guy I wouldn't have I wouldn't
have uh rallied to throw him out but I
also didn't think he was the most
conservative guy either and I thought
okay Matt Gates has this opportunity
he's going to throw him out we'll see
what happens and all the establishment
types they whined they cried oh no we're
losing the great speaker this is going
to throw the house into chaos what did
that chaos get us that chaos got us a
strong conservative speaker in Mike
Johnson and it killed this stupid bill
this bill
it's not as though this would just be ah
we got to you know take our medicine we
conservatives this bill would have
radically expanded immigration and would
have given Democrats a generational
electoral
Advantage is Matt Gates Vindicated here
I think Matt Gates might be a little bit
Vindicated okay because while the GOP
establishment whed and cried and moaned
about tossing out McCarthy whom I still
think is fine maybe McCarthy would have
killed the bill to I don't know but I
know for a fact Johnson would kill the
bill seems to be working out just fine
now speaking of illegal aliens everyone
everyone other than Chuck Schumer and
Mitch McConnell apparently in the
country knows that this immigration
situation is just horrible including CNN
CNN just ran a segment on on the chaos
in New York City right now where illegal
aliens are going around robbing people
mugging people assaulting people
dragging people from the back of mopeds
just absolutely terrorizing the city and
even the libs on CNN are saying this
looks really bad within that group this
hardworking you know throngs of people
in search of Hope and a better life
there is this 1center you know criminal
element that looks at a different
opportunity here these individuals I
went over their wrap sheets yesterday
multiple charges Grand larsy robbery
attempted robbery grand larsy grand
larsy uh this particular crew operated
on mopeds and scooters they were doing
organized retail theft they were doing
snatches on the street iPhones iPads
clothing so on and so forth um one of
them that they are still seeking has 10
charges on one day because he's part of
a pattern that's been going on and I'm
looking at the dates that their arrest
started which is probably close to when
they got here they've only been here a
couple of months so what the detectives
are telling me is they have Crews here
that operate in New York do all their
stealing then go to Florida to spend the
money and then come back and I'm like
well why don't they just stay in steel
in Florida and they said cuz there you
go to jail
oh not only calling attention to the
problem but pointing out it's a
political problem it's not even just
about where the migrants are going
plenty of migrants go to Florida too
says no in New York you get off the hook
when you commit a crime because New York
is run by democrats Florida you go to
jail the layers of honesty from CNN I'm
not sure that I've ever seen from them
you seen this out of the New York city
mayor too though remember the New York
city mayor came out and he said that
illegal immigration was going to destroy
New York City he then had an appointment
scheduled to meet with the Biden White
House about this and just before that
meeting all of a sudden investigators
start poking around into corruption
allegations against the New York city
mayor kind of funny how that works isn't
it everybody knows this is a disaster
Joe Biden knows this is a disaster for
him but what are they going to do about
it what can they do the best thing they
can do they're not going to stop the
migration they're not going to stop it
because it is the Democrats long-term
strategy it just might hurt them in the
short term so the the only thing they
can do is put together some awful Bill
to get to trick Republicans into signing
on to it so that the Democrats can blame
Republicans or share some of the blame
with Republicans for the migration
situation which is entirely the
democrat's fault and these doofuses in
Washington DC in the Republican party
want to take the bait they're begging
please conservatives let's go along with
this we don't want the Democrats to Bear
all the blame for maybe the most
important political issue to Americans
and to people throughout the West for
the last decade the issue that prompted
brexit that prompted the election of of
leaders in Europe from Hungary to Italy
almost to Spain to Sweden to Germany no
no hey let's let's just give up our
advantage what a
bunch of dummies good grief I'm glad
that the conservatives seem to be
holding the line
here but don't when CNN tells you what
what this is all about you should
believe them okay when CNN admits oh man
this is looking bad you should believe
them now what what can we do for our
country well we certainly should pray
for our country that's why you got to
check out hallow right now go to
hall.com
lent the 40 days leading up to Easter
starts on Ash Wednesday Ash Wednesday is
the day after Marty gr that is Fat
Tuesday and Ash Wednesday this year
falls on St Valentine's Day this is a
time of intense prayer fasting and
giving Hallow's annual pray 40 challenge
is one of their most popular last year
over 1 million people joined this year's
pray 40 challenge focuses on surrender
and includes meditations on the powerful
book he leadth me a story about a priest
who became a prisoner and slave in the
Soviet Union during the Cold War his
story is one of Ultimate Surrender and
we are called to offer up our own
worries anxieties problems and lives to
God there will also be Lenton music lent
specific Bible stories and other Lenton
prayers such as Seven Last Words of
Christ with Jim cisel hallow is truly
transformative it will help you connect
with your faith on a deeper level so
what are you waiting for download the
hall app today at hall.com
for an exclusive three-month free trial
of all 6,000 plus prayers and
meditations that is hall.com
slns if you want to protect your kids
from the leftist indoctrination in the
establishment media this is how you
start a 14-day free trial to Bent key
the New Kids Entertainment app from the
daily wire bent key is the only
streaming app with highquality
family-friendly shows that reflect your
beliefs featuring amazing characters and
Timeless stories beny will spark your
kids imagination with hundreds of
episodes that you can trust and remember
Saturday morning cartoons well we
brought them back with new episode
streaming every Saturday morning but
don't take my word for it see for
yourself try bent key for free for 14
days no catch no gimmick no hidden fees
just fabulous content that your kids
will love use code unlock bent key.com
you will get 14 days of unlimited access
to beny's World of Adventure go to B
key.com use code unlock it sign up to
start your free trial
today speaking of New York a New York
Court has just ruled that a father
cannot stop his eight-year-old child
from
[Music]
being but this time I'm stronger with
you now speaking of our Brave New
World have you seen the people wearing
these dumb Apple things apples come out
with goggles and they're goggles you put
them on your head and I think there's
audio associated with it and it covers
up half your face and they cost 3500
bucks plus 200 bucks for a battery pack
but here's the here's the promise is if
you spend a lot of money and you put
these dumb looking goggles on your face
you get to live inside a cell phone you
get do you ever think in your modern
life you think you know I just don't
look at enough screens I I wish I could
spend more time I wish my phone were
more immersive and I didn't have to look
at you know uh this beautiful Earth and
Sky that God gave to us to live in real
life in our flesh I wish I could just
ignore all that so I could be on my cell
phone more well then have I got the
product for you it's the Apple Vision
Pro some guy just got pulled over for
driving it was a Tesla so I guess it was
a self-driving car but he was driving
with his Apple goggles on and the video
starts out all sort of nice
he's he's not touching the steering
wheel he's it it looks like he's casting
a magic spell of sorts cuz he's typing
onto the air so it it actually kind of
looks like he's Jordan Peterson you know
like he's doing one of these things with
his hands you know man but he's not but
without any of the wisdom you know
without any of the insightful
observations and then it immediately
cuts to the guy gets pulled over by a
police office
officer CS Lewis observed in the great
divorce that the people who are in Hell
want to be there hell is a place that
you
choose hell is where you go by your own
desire because you do not turn your
desire and behavior toward God you turn
it in the other direction and you get
what you want that's the that's the
amazing thing about Freedom whether we
follow it in a proper way or we abuse it
is you tend to get what you
want if you to told not just George
Orwell but Aldis
Huxley in the in the early to mid 20th
century if you said Hey in the
future people are going to be so
addicted to screens and to constant
titilation and to just buzzes and alarms
and a ton of porn by the way that at a
certain point they're going to block out
their own vision they're going to choose
to put these goggles on and blur out the
real world so that they can watch sports
and porn all day even while they're
driving Huxley would believe you George
Orwell would think that that would be
imposed by a tyranical totalitarian
government Huxley was smarter though
because while George Orwell in 1984
believes that our our loss of freedom is
going to come through the heavy hand of
the state Alis Huxley and New World
recognizes no it's going to be the
carrot not the stick he recognizes no
it's going to be the enticement it's
going to be the temptation to all sorts
of low pleasures and and to all sorts of
vices that's what's going to get us it's
going to be drugs and sex and
promiscuity and just physical pleasure
and that's what's going to happen I can
think of no product that I would I would
less enjoy than the Apple Vision
Pro but a lot of lot of people are going
to buy this thing it's it's expensive so
it's that is naturally going to limit
who can buy it but a lot of people are
going to desire this thing that's for
sure they're going to live in virtual
reality which they have convinced
themselves is is more beautiful and
interesting than reality reality but
it's not and this by the way this is in
part why we have the people just no
longer value the physical world they
they only value the virtual and digital
world in in which a man can really
become a woman cuz their bodies don't
matter but I I still prefer the physical
world and I would encourage you not to
plug not to voluntarily plug yourself
into the Matrix where you can watch
football and pornography all day long
speaking of our changing political
order sad news coming out of the UK this
is
news about which most Americans will not
care but I do care actually his majesty
King Charles III has been diagnosed with
cancer uh King Charles you know just
became king his mother reigned for 70
years and then he ascended to the throne
when she died and he was he was just
crowned what a year or two ago and uh he
went in for a a routine kind of prostate
uh procedure which men of a certain age
virtually all undergo and while they
were in there they found that he had
some kind of cancer nonprostate cancer
some other kind of cancer the Buckingham
Palace has not been totally clear about
what cancer that is
and I just think we ought to pray for
King Charles I know we broke away from
those limes back in
1776 I
know some Catholics don't really like
the The Windsor because they're
Protestant or okay sure but some
conservatives don't like King Charles
because they say he's a world economic
Forum environmentalist stooge or what
cuz he divorced his wife I know I know I
I know all the Litany of charges against
King
Charles
nevertheless that man is I think by his
inclination but certainly by his
office one of the most traditionalist
and conservative people left on the face
of the Earth even King Charles's
environmentalism is very very
conservative because he's not an
environmentalist in the way that your
lesbian cousin is an environmentalist
you know your lesbian vegan cousin with
silly colored hair who shows up to
Thanksgiving and yells at you for eating
turkey that's not the kind of
environmentalist King Charles is King
Charles is the kind of environmentalist
who wants to protect the woodlands on
his property so he can continue to hunt
foxes and that's extremely conservative
King jles is the kind of
environmentalist who believes we need to
protect the world so that the natural
world so that we can continue to enjoy
it because it's beautiful and old and
traditional he's the kind of
environmentalist who likes the
environment because he opposes rampant
liberal capitalism and industrialization
that's very conservative that's very
very traditional the British crown is is
one of the few remaining even quasi
conservative institutions in the world
and so anyway that's my long rant and
diet tribe to uh pray for King Charles
because even though we Americans we
think we don't we know who cares about
the British crown even plenty of people
in the UK say oh whatever get rid of the
ground you will miss that
institution if it ever goes away you
will miss it because there will be a lot
of
dignity that will disappear there will
be there will be un
unlearned knowledge that just kind of
gets passed down hered through through
the generations as a matter of heredity
it will disappear and you will miss it
when it's gone now speaking of mortality
you ought to check out trust and will
right now go to trustand will.com for
maintaining control of your ass assets
to easing the burden on your loved ones
to taking care of your kids an estate
plan can ensure that your family is
prepared and protected I have had a will
since I was 18 years old and it gives me
great peace of mind that was even when I
was just a single guy I wasn't married
with kids when you're married and you
have kids you need to have a will you
need to set up your estate to offer
Financial benefits and more you got to
check out trust and will traditional
estate planning can cost thousands of
dollars many one-size fits Solutions may
not capture all the important details of
the life you've built with trust and
will it is super duper easy you can
protect the legacy of your family from
the comfort of your own home and it
starts at just 159 bucks which is
incredibly inexpensive and super duper
simple protect your loved ones with
trust and will secure those assets get
10% off plus free shipping on all of
your estate plan documents by visiting
trustand will.com canw that is 10% off
in free shipping at trustand will.com
/ns my favorite comment yesterday comes
from the drummers Workshop Norms music
who says I have a feeling that that
Bronx judge attended a lot more parties
than Brett Kavanaugh very true the lives
went after Justice Kavanagh during his
confirmation hearings because when he
was 16 he went to a beer party or
something in high school meanwhile you
got that Bronx family judge who's on the
threa map trying to pick up the lady
whose case she's
adjudicating yeah I don't know whatever
the libs accuse us of it seems that
they're guilty of it 10 times over now
speaking of leaders and heads of state
president
Trump is reportedly considering two
people in particular to be his vice
president he made these comments he has
been a little tight lipped about who
he's considering but he said he's
considering on the short list Tim Scott
senator from South Carolina and Christy
gome governor of South Dakota and I like
Tim Scott very much I don't know chrisy
Nome but she she was a fine Governor she
made a few errors but all in all she she
was better than average for sure the
idea here I think would be that these
people would balance the
ticket Trump is white Tim Scott is black
Trump is a dude Christine Nome is a
woman Trump comes from the rightwing of
the Republican party it's a little
complicated but basically he comes from
the right-wing of the party the Reagan
Side Of The Party The Goldwater side of
the party
and Scott and gnome come from the more
liberal side the more bush side of the
party the more whatever that's a little
unfair to gome she was a little more
rock ribed but
still broadly speaking a little more
amenable to the corporate Chamber of
Commerce interest of the Republican
Party okay fine fine I guess I don't
know though because Trump is he's a
youthful man in his gate but he
chronologically he's a little long in
the tooth so a vice president matters
more for a Republican
who's 70 or 80 than it would for a
republican who's 40 or
50 and though I like Tim Scott a lot and
chrisye N seems fine I would feel more
comfortable with a more Conservative
Vice President so if president Trump
wants to balance out the ticket either
with a racial minority or with a woman
to me there's a very clear answer the
the clear person who should be the vice
president for Trump if if that's what
he's going for is marshia Blackburn in
Tennessee my own Senator
here the the reason being she's a rock
ribbed conservative but she's very
clubbable she's amenable to a broad
array of people she's not scary she's
not stupid she's obviously a very bright
woman she's very dignified she comports
herself with a great
class and she's a conservative now you
might say well Michael Trump's already
going to win Tennessee yeah sure he's
also going to win South Carolina and
South Dakota he doesn't need any help to
win those States so it's not as I'm I'm
skeptical that a vice president ever
totally can bring a state over but in as
much as a a VP can they're not going to
do it so if that's already baked in and
you want someone to balance the ticket
why wouldn't you go for the very
conservative very loyal to Trump choice
of Maria Blackburn I think she would be
a great option now there are other
options if he doesn't care to have a
woman or he doesn't care to have a
racial minority JD Vance in Ohio I think
could be a very good choice there are a
number of other people I'm not limiting
I'm just saying given what we know about
Trump's calculations from his own
statements on who he's
considering though I like Tim Scott a
lot and Christine om seems just
fine if it were me if president Trump
were to call me tomorrow said Michael
what do you think Buddy what's your
choice seems to me that the way Trump is
thinking Marsha Blackburn would be a
perfect choice now speaking of
Republican
politicians there is a great new bill
being put forward by a house Republican
that every house Republicans should get
behind the the Republicans in the house
they're doing a good job right now
they're killing that dumb immigration
Bill and now they are proposing the face
act repeal this is coming by way of
Congressman chip Roy and I think it's
absolutely great and every Republican
should back chip Roy's plan the face Act
was a law signed by Bill Clinton in 1994
it's the freedom of access to Clinic
entrances act it was it was a way to
protect abortion clinics from CR
ISM because in the 9s the libs claimed
that the poor the poor beleaguered
abortionists the poor baby murderers
were being threatened too much and so we
we had to figure out a way to stop
people from threatening them but it
wasn't really just about threats the
face act very quickly became weaponized
to stop conservatives from peaceful
protests peaceful demonstrations you're
seeing pro-lifers being prosecuted and
sent to prison for more than a decade
for this sort of thing right now and it
was controversial at the time so the
Liberals gave the conservatives a bone
and they said okay well in the face act
we'll also stop people from intimidating
uh uh churchgoers we'll stop people from
vandalizing churches Joe Biden has not
prosecuted one of these cases a face act
case against someone attacking a church
it just doesn't happen it was bogus it
was it was a a total distraction this
act is about the protecting baby
murderers from criticism act that's what
you could call it and so Chip Roy very
wisely
and very courageously just came out and
said let's repeal this stupid thing and
I absolutely think it's a great idea and
and I rarely get on my soapbox on this
show and say call your Congressman but
when it comes to the face act repeal
call your Congressman tag your
Congressman if you're watching this on
YouTube tag your Congressman on YouTube
if you're watching this on Twitter tag
on X tag your Congressman if you're
watching this on dailywire plus send
this link
around this is a great bill every
Republican should get behind this and it
it's it's an urgent matter because
people are being prosecuted under this
stupid law this face act right now and
good people are going to prison for
Having the courage to stand up for the
most defenseless Among
Us call your
Congressman now speaking of women's
issues there is breaking news this is
real tabloid stuff gilain Maxwell the
Paramore and business partner of Jeffrey
Epstein is apparently going to write a
tell all
book about her experience with Jeffrey
and on the island here is the talk TV
exclusive from gilain Maxwell in prison
no he didn't I don't believe he
did I believe that he
was maded I was shocked and I wondered
how has it happened so she goes it's not
not a very long clip actually she she's
asked do you think Jeffrey Epstein kill
himself she says says no fste didn't
kill himself I think he was murdered I
don't know how it happened uh but I'm
going to tell my
story the rest of the the reason I
didn't play the rest of the clip is it's
her complaining about prison food you
know it's her complaining about the way
that she's been treated in prison it's
just it's nothing and it's a it's a sign
that you're not going to get anything
out of this book look if it comes out I
I guess I'll probably read it or I'll
skim it at
least you're not learning anything about
Epstein every time there's a
drip ah new information we're about to
unseal The Client List right before
Christmas I I made my predictions for
2024 I said you're not going to learn
anything new about Epstein really
nothing substantively new and then 24
hours later breaking news we're going to
unseal the Epstein Client List thought
oh maybe I'm wrong no I'm not wrong you
know what it's going to be we're going
to find out the same stuff we already
knew oh Bill Clinton flew on the
airplane okay Alan dersu it's was was
Epstein's lawyer yeah we knew that
Epstein was a member of maral Lago
uhhuh sure what what new information are
we going to get nothing and you know why
because Alex aosta the US attorney who
prosecuted Jeffrey
Epstein said that he heard from higher
ups that Jeffrey Epstein belongs to
intelligence and we know that his gain
Maxwell's uh father was connected to
Israeli intelligence and British
intelligence and maybe Russian
intelligence and we know that Jeffrey
Epstein apparently had some relationship
with American
intelligence and they're not going to
let us find out anything so we can keep
seeing the headlines oh big tell all
here we go yeah okay we will
learn the the truth about Jeffrey
Epstein only when the intelligence
agencies want us to know about it and I
would not hold my breath for that the
rest of the show continues now you don't
want to miss it become a member use code
NES kwes a check out for two months free
on all annual
plans
[Music]
a